what are the eight common archetypes or
psychological functions found in most
stories well you know when I was sort of
composing my model of Storytelling I
looked to the work of Carl Jung who had
made this hypothesis that there is some
kind of
Collective unconsciousness
and that out of that which is like the
dreaming State or the unconscious mind
of an individual person the whole
culture has got a swirling cloud of
ideas and energies and that out of that
there were some common things that he
noticed and he called those common forms
or characters sometimes he called those
archetypes and the word means uh
a version that's very very old the
original version of something so the
archetypes are kind of uh core beliefs
or uh almost models of from which all
kinds of other variations can be
described but the ones that I found most
useful were first of all the hero who
stands for uh you know an idealized
version of ourselves uh it's somebody
who is maybe more
athletic or successful or bold or Brave
or uh funny or some in some way is a
little bit exaggerated
but has qualities that we would like to
have and so we project ourselves into
that hero the next one that I studied
was the mentor because I noticed that a
lot of stories like Star Wars have
strong relationships between a young
hero and an older Master like the Jedi
Masters uh the various ones that you
find in in the Star Wars saga and that
was a very interesting study how those
teachers and student
relationships uh developed and and you
could get a lot of comedy and a lot of
drama out of those the next thing would
be the shape shifters because
um it seemed as I studied many movie
examples and fairy tales and so forth
that there was often a character
who might be a love interest or a friend
or an ally for the hero but their nature
was always a little bit Shifty and they
sometimes appeared to be friendly or to
be useful allies and at times maybe
there was danger of betrayal or
disappointment so their nature is kind
of Shifting and I think that reflects
how people relate to other people
that you know you form first impressions
of people and then maybe you learn more
about them and you see they were there
was more there or less there than I
thought so uh that term shapeshifter
refers to the way that people's
appearance or their mask or their
behavior might change quite a lot in the
course of a story or in life and are
puzzling sometimes to the hero the hero
has to figure out that's one of the
tasks of the hero is to figure out who
am I really dealing with in other people
around him or her so shapeshifter is
kind of a catch-all for those and this
is where I put all of the Romantic
relationships but also the Buddy comedy
relationships that they fall into that
same pattern because typically one
member of this two-person team that's
thrown together usually one person is
pretty fixed and for term in their
appearance and their attitudes and so
forth and the other one is kind of
Shifty and untrustworthy or mysterious
and this is uh a human thing that we all
encounter we kind of know who we are to
a limited extent but we kind of have a
sense of ourselves and then we meet
other people and maybe have to work with
them and find
there's more than meets the eye so the
shape shifter is kind of a place where I
park all these romantic and
friendship and Alliance and business
kind of relationships because they do
have this aspect of of trying to figure
out who am I really dealing with
and then the next archetype I guess that
uh
comes into play is the shadow which is
the dark reflection of the hero and uh I
made an assumption when I started
working with these ideas that oh well
this is where we put all the villains
they're they're the Shadows they're the
dark version of the hero and when the
hero is up the villain is down and
disappointed and when the hero is in big
trouble the the villain is on top of
things and uh feels great so uh it does
cover that and and I think that's a
useful way to look at villains that
they're kind of the Dark Shadow version
of the hero but it also it's a much
bigger term in jungian
archetypal theory that includes uh all
the stuff within yourself
that you are suspicious of or you don't
trust or you don't like or you're
ashamed of or you're afraid of
traumatic events in the past that you
don't want to think about all of that
lives in an area inside of our
psychology that's called The Shadow so
it's both the name for individual
characters who might be wearing that
mask of a threat to the hero or the dark
version of the hero but it also can be a
space
within the hero or even within a society
where all that dark stuff or repressed
stuff is hidden and it has certain rules
that I think are very interesting for
composing stories that the shadow tends
to get stronger the more you deny it so
admitting to things and revealing things
to yourself and and exploring and
dredging up
unconscious material is usually a
healthy thing it's difficult but uh
getting the shadow out into the light is
a good idea and I think vampires as a
literary uh creation uh are a really
good expression of that shadow idea
because technically they're supposed to
uh disappear into a puff of Ash or
something when they come out into the
sunlight and it's the same with these
shadow things they have a lot of power
when they're held down and repressed
they become quite dangerous but when you
let them out it's not so bad and they
lose their power when we shine some
light on them
so next thing up is uh very useful one
archetype that called the threshold
guardian and this is something that my
mentor Joseph Campbell
wrote about extensively and I found it
really useful in life the idea is that
every time you come to a Crossroads in
life every time you come to a boundary
between one way of living and another or
one world and another there seems to be
somebody or something there at the
border guarding that transition
and possibly blocking you like a
policeman uh stopping you uh demanding
payment
uh or telling you to go away
and uh it's one of the tasks of a hero
is learning how to deal with that and
it's inevitable these things are going
to come up sometimes it's a character in
a story sometimes it's a force like a
huge rock slide or a waterfall or
something that's blocking your path but
the heroes have to figure out ways to
get around it over it under it through
it to embrace it to seduce it to uh
bring it into your parade along with
everything else
and not be stopped by it that's the
basic key and I've just found this so
useful in life and in my career
that often I will meet an obstacle and I
will think this is fatal this is going
to destroy me this is going to ruin my
ambition
and then I realize no it's just a
threshold guardian and so I knowing that
I can make friends with it I can bring
it on to my side I can figure out how to
wit it or trick it it's it's just an
extremely useful tool in life as well as
in stories
so next thing up is a kind of delightful
archetype called the trickster
and this is one that has a long long
history that goes back into myths and
fairy tales all the way back to the
earliest Tales we know from the
Egyptians and from folk stories all over
the world the idea of a funny Little
Critter who doesn't have all the cards
he's not big and scary but he's clever
or there's a lot of him like a lot of
rabbits or a lot of ants and as an
individual they don't have much power at
all but collectively they have a lot of
power and they can even be stronger or
smarter than a big creature like a bear
or something scary like that and these
stories you know have their long long
history and we still enjoy stories like
this
when I think about the Warner Brothers
cartoons about Wiley Coyote uh and uh
and the Roadrunner you know the Road
Runner is uh would be helpless in the
jaws of the coyote but he never gets in
the Jaws because he's smarter than the
coyote and has a million ways of
outwitting him and using his own energy
against him uh he's he's a very clever
example of this this archetype of the
trickster and there are many in
different cultures Native Americans talk
about various creatures like the Raven
and sometimes the coyote himself being
the the clever one who can out with the
the bigger scarier creatures and it also
is a place to put in your thinking all
of the clowns all of the humor and
sometimes uh this is a kind of a mask
that is worn by characters in the story
they become funny in order to do some
job they become clever and are able to
outwit uh the the stronger characters
who who should have all the advantages
but this this kind of trickster
mentality gives them some advantages and
then
um
the the last one that uh I added in
later additions to my book it was kind
of an afterthought but it was very
important is the Ally that
um a lot of characters in stories Heroes
and stories
um are limited in some way they don't
have much of a sense of humor uh they
are infallible or they have to be right
all the time and they really need
somebody to go alongside of them
kidding them joking with them deflating
them when they get a big ego
giving to the audience something very
important which is called comic relief
that this is a belief of Shakespeare's
is that if I'm going to clobber the
audience with really heavy emotions and
make them cry or make them horrified by
the behavior of the characters I better
leaven that just a little bit with
something funny and so he would often
put into his most serious Place uh a
little Joker character uh who would
maybe be a drunken guard at the gate or
an old family retainer or somebody in in
the court who is there to make fun of
the the king and the the fancy people
and I just love this uh this aspect of
allies is that sometimes they have that
comic role they overlap with the
tricksters a little bit but they bring
balance to a character and we really
really like this form of uh two people
going through a and adventure together
who are quite different they contrast
quite a lot like Sherlock Holmes is this
cold intellectual and he's balanced by
the warmth and the heart and sometimes
the foolishness of Dr Watson so the two
are not exactly mirror images they're
maybe broken mirror images of each other
but you put the two of them together and
you get a complete human being and I
think that's a great way to think about
these archetypes is that they're all
aspects of human life
and everybody has got some of these
characteristics and some of these masks
available to them and so it's a great
thing I think to study
psychology and how it comes out in the
movies
and see you know what archetypes am I
expressing at this moment at this moment
I'm expressing a kind of a mentor
teacher archetype but I I may slide out
of this chair and fall down so then we'd
have the the trickster appearing
so uh you know we we have access to all
those things and that's what makes a
complete human being
and sorry did we speak about the herald
ah I knew I left one out yes it's uh
thank you for reminding me I've
forgotten uh the poor character The
Herald the archetype of the herald uh
maybe the reason that I left that one
out is that uh it is less
um essential than the others uh its job
can be done by any of the others but the
function sometimes is Broken Out In a
story and given to a specific individual
character uh to be the one who brings
the message who usually brings the Call
to Adventure and it could be in a simple
thing like a western uh some guy comes
running out of the telegraph office and
says Sheriff the bad guys just got out
of jail and they're going to be on the
train at noon so you better gone up and
be ready because they're coming to get
you to get the revenge and then perhaps
that character is never in the story
again or they may come back later with
other warnings but the job is that of
the old Heralds in the medieval courts
who wore a certain costume and had
usually a trumpet
to blow announcements and to say the
king is dead long live the king or the
new king or they would say there's a
princess available for marriage and we'd
like all the local princes to come
around and see which one is the best or
let's declare war or let's declare peace
or you know some important announcement
has to be made and mythologically
this goes along with
a character who flies from the world of
the Gods down to earth to bring messages
and that's Hermes
um and or Mercury as the Romans called
him and that was his job and he shows up
probably more than any other character
in mythology because he was so useful he
was always flying up to heaven reporting
on things down on Earth and then sending
down the will of the gods to the the
heroes and people on Earth and uh so he
did that Herald function very
effectively